now we're going to get to division now
addition subtraction moment everything
seems pretty normal so far right but
when you get to division
I'm going to give you an example to
think about to ponder before I show you
how to do it so just write down this as
an example okay so this is the question
we're gonna do in about three minutes
but before we do that I want you to
ponder how would you even start such a
question right here
the the familiar rules of ribbon
thirteen serves you very well I know how
to add stuff I know how to multiply
stuff but when you look at this guy what
where do I go right I'm expecting I
should get a single complex number at
the end I've got a pair of them right so
what could I do with this okay
now rationalizing denominators it's a
really helpful idea but rationalizing
makes sense when what you've got is an
irrational number now I have no square
roots there I would get two square roots
soon okay well I don't have any
rationalizing doesn't make sense right
because it's not it's not the fact that
it's irrational that's the problem right
the problem is that I have one of their
parts in there okay but this is a very
helpful idea let's have a think about
this right if I went back to say
actually I've already got one that's a
little something like this okay so
remember I said I'm going to take my
cues for the way irrational numbers
works this is a good Ally to go down
okay if I gave you this question
here's a question that has to do with
just irrational limits right he's five
plus three
yeah
now in this case what happens is rules
kick in right you're like I know what to
do with this regardless of why I know
how to handle this can someone tell me
what to do what shall I do to simplify
this yep very good multiply the top okay
now the reason why this is useful is
because you've got a rational number and
it's trying to play all with an
irrational number
and what do it right so that's why we
multiply this by this because conjugates
let us use a difference of squares okay
so we're not going to finish this off
because it gets a bit messy up here but
I just want to get the first line so you
can see what will happen okay you've got
this eight flying around front you're
gonna get this somewhat messy expansion
up the top but it'll work but please
tell me and this time super fat for me
because you can what are we going to get
on the denominator when everything comes
out in the wash you're gonna get 22
right because you've got a squared minus
B Square that's gonna be 25 take away 3
and the reason why that's good is
because now that you've got a rational
denominator it can work together with
everything else in that question cool so
now you have a look at this now the
problem is not that the denominator is
irrational the problem is it has
imaginary things in it things that
aren't real right so therefore to make
it play ball well instead of making
things rational I want to make them real
so when you make something rational we
call that rationalizing so if you want
to make something real what do you think
that would be calling here it's called
realizing so we're going to realize this
denominator okay
not like realize we're just gonna change
it multiplied by the conjugate which in
this case is 2 minus 3i
and this is gonna allow us to actually
compute with this okay so let's have a
go of this we're going to do this
properly now on the top there I'm just
gonna write that first like I did up
here and I'm dealing on there so I've
got negative 14 plus 5 by 2 minus 3i on
okay think we'd be right dude some
difference of squares down here unlike
here I'm super comfortable we were doing
real numbers but here I don't want to
[ __ ] this up so down here I'm gonna have
to square takeaway so so I'm gonna write
the square just like ivory I know I
couldn't win that school but I've heard
it is 2 squared so I screw it up hey I'm
going to write her three eyes wait are
you comfortable with that
right there's so many negative signs
here you're sort of asking for Eddie to
try and do that ball in your hair the
same time you'll get there Mitchell ages
we can start to unravel this now okay um
this top here is the question we did
before so let me get [ __ ] 28 14 by 3 is
42 42 what's your size 10 I - 15i
squared happy okay now we can do in this
denominator so you've got 4 and then
you've got minus 3i squared the 3 will
become a 9 so I will become up okay so
you're gonna start to get a theme here
right where you guys quite quickly
taught me 22 before cuz you're like 25
take away 3 I know what to do with this
because of that I in there you don't get
the difference of squares you actually
end up getting a son did you notice that
because the I will always give you that
plus sign rendering there does that make
sense yes okay
species out that maybe 15 I squared it's
going to become a plus 15 so that leaves
you with a real Plateau
maybe 13 what's my imaginary part on T
which conveniently leaves you with or
not conveniently because I made up this
question to give me any numbers okay so
so what have you done you've realized
the denominator and that allowed you to
well get rid of the Tanami
okay I will point out yeah the numbers
don't always obviously end up that make
for example if all I had was this
equation changed into the abyss okay
okay now there's nothing wrong with that
you know sometimes when you get the
question and the numbers don't don't
come out neatly you get a little bit
suspicious okay
these happen all the time you've seen
before even earlier on we just solved a
very simple quadratic it's not even like
rationals you get square roots in here
and that happens frequently so in
freaked out in this case though usually
we would say no go to the next line
write it with the real part and the
imaginary part separately even it gives
you something somewhat messy
I would prefer writing this like this
okay because it's in that form a plus bi
or I've been whichever don't really know
okay but that's just a matter of
notation it's not that important okay
all right
that's written that's it now you can see
it's like not so familiar but sorry not
your like if you say someone in the
library like you're working together
you're like I better realize that
denominator some two no three in your
studio look at you like what's wrong
with you like do you not know what
that's going you're like ha ha ha I knew
things you don't so it's familiar but at
the same time kind of strange